♪
>> Emily: AMERICANS HAVE HAD
ENOUGH OF THE LIBERAL MEDIA
BIAS, AND THE PRESS PRAISING
JOE BIDEN WHILE ATTACKING
REPUBLICANS AT EVERY TURN.
A NEW POLL SHOWS OVERWHELMING
DISTRUST.
JUST 16% OF AMERICANS HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN WHAT THEY HEAR
FROM TV NEWS.
YOU HAVE TO ASSUME IT'S BECAUSE
OF EXAMPLES LIKE THIS.
>> THIS WAS THE SWAB THE NURSE
WAS ACTUALLY USING ON YOU, AND
IT DISAPPEARED, SO THAT IN SCALE
THIS WAS THE ACTUAL SWAB THAT
WAS BEING USED.
>> YOU ARE ALL PLACES.
PEOPLE WOULD BE FOOLISH TO
UNDERESTIMATE MICHAEL AVENATTI.
>> MICHAEL AVENATTI IS A BEAST.
>> Emily: CONGRESS IS THE ONLY
ONE TRUSTED GLASS.
GREG GUTFELD, PRESIDENT BIDEN
HAS RECEIVED LESS NEGATIVE
COVERAGE THAN ANY PRESIDENT IN
30 YEARS ACCORDING TO PEW.
CONTRACT THAT WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO PRESS
COVERAGE THAT WAS 90% NEGATIVE.
NO WONDER EVERYBODY DISTRUSTS
THE MEDIA.
>> Greg: IT'S NOT A SURPRISE
THAT THE BIAS ONLY GOES IN ONE
DIRECTION.
THE PROBLEM IS IT CAN'T BE
FIXED.
I THINK IT'S DONE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE EMBRACED THE SUNK COST OF
THEIR PAST.
THERE'S NO WAY CNN CAN CHANGE
THE MENTALITY.
THEY'VE BEEN ANTI-COP FOR A
DECADE, AND I WE ARE SEEING IT
ALL PLAY OUT ON THE STREETS.
THEY CAN'T ADMIT IT.
THE ONLY TIME THEY EVER ADMITTED
IT WHEN WHEN THEY SAID IT COULD
AFFECT JOE BIDEN POLITICALLY.
THEY DIDN'T ACTUALLY SAY, YOU
KNOW WHAT?
WE REALLY SCREWED UP.
THE ONLY WAY TO SENSE HOW THE
MEDIA WORKS IS BECOME THE TOPIC.
WRITE?
CAN I USE AN ANALOGY?
LET'S SAY THERE'S A NATIONAL
WEBSITE THAT YOU PUT YOUR NAME
IN AND IT TELLS YOU YOUR BODY
WEIGHT.
SO YOU PUT YOUR NAME IN AND YOU
PUT IN YOUR BODY, AND IT'S
COMPLETELY WRONG.
YOU KNOW THAT IS INACCURATE, BUT
NOBODY ELSE DOES.
THAT'S HOW THE MEDIA IS ABLE TO
SURVIVE.
THE ONLY PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND
THE FAKENESS OF THE MEDIA ARE
THE PEOPLE HAVE SUDDENLY BECOME
THE SUBJECT MATTER.
THE MOMENT YOU ARE IN AN ARTICLE
AND THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT YOU,
YOU GO, MY GOD, THIS IS A SCAM
AND A SHAM AND THEY ONLY WANT TO
HURT YOU.
>> Emily: TOTALLY.
JESSICA, THE ARGUMENT SORT OF
FLIES OUT THE WINDOW WHEN YOU
SEE ALSO LOSS OF THE AMOUNT OF
COVERAGE AND WHAT IT WENT DOWN
TO.
FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN IT GOES DOWN
INTO THE MUNDANE.
REMEMBER WHEN WE KILLED
QASSEM SOLEIMANI AND IT WAS
REPORTED THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS ENJOYING HIS ICE CREAM WHEN
HE LEARNED ABOUT THE AIR STRIKE?
THEY FOUND A WAY TO COVER
EVERYTHING AND INSERT A NEGATIVE
SLANT.
>> Jessica: I'VE SEEN THE
STUDIES, OBVIOUSLY, FROM THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
I WOULD NEVER DENY THAT THE
PRESS CORPS IS HAVING AN EASIER
TIME WITH THE BY DEMONSTRATION.
HEART OF THAT IS JOE BIDEN
DOESN'T HIT THE PRESS, AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP HATED THE PRESS
AND CAMPAIGN ON IT.
>> Jesse: WHY WOULD YOU HIT
THE PRESS IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT?
>> Jessica: I THINK YOU CAN
HAVE A HEALTHY RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE PRESS AS A DEMOCRAT.
WE QUESTION EACH OTHER AND
RESPECT AND OUT CONDENSATE NEWS.
AND THEN YOU CAN GET ALONG AND
STILL BE PUSHED.
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN PUSHED ON THE
NUMBER OF DECISIONS HE'S MADE.
>> Greg: YOU'VE GOT TO EARN
RESPECT, JESSICA.
THERE'S NO WAY ANYBODY ON THE
RIGHT SHOULD RESPECT THE MEDIA.
AFTER 40 YEARS, SINCE THE
'60s.
>> Jesse: HERE'S HOW THE MEDIA
PRESS IS BIDEN.
>> Jessica: BECAUSE I WENT TO
CELL CYCLE, I BARELY --
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: YOU NEED TO TAKE THAT
TO HR.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jessica: BUT THIS IS A
LONGTIME TREND ON BOTH SIDES.
LIBERALS DON'T TRUST
CONSERVATIVE MEDIA.
THERE IS THE TRUST BAROMETER
THAT'S BEEN MEASURING THIS FOR A
VERY LONG TIME.
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING TO PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS, PRIVATE SECTOR
COMPANIES, TO MAKE UP THE
DIFFERENCE.
BECAUSE I DON'T LIKE CONGRESS,
THEY DON'T LIKE THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES, AND THEY DON'T
TRUST THE INFORMATION BEING FED
TO THEM.
IT'S DANGEROUS.
THE FACT THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE DOING FANTASTIC WORK AT
THEIR --
>> Greg: THE CONSERVATIVE
MEDIA IS NEW.
IT AROSE BECAUSE OF THIS
IMBALANCE.
NOW THEY ARE MAD THAT
CONSERVATIVE MEDIA IS BEATING
THE CRAP OUT OF THEM.
>> Emily: TO THAT POINT,
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN REP
DOMINIC REPUBLICANS IN
CONFIDENCE
WITH IT HAS TO BE EARNED.
AND THEY SEE IT.
STEEL AND DEMOCRATS DON'T TRUST
CONSERVATIVE MEDIA BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WATCH CONSERVATIVE MEDIA.
>> Jessica: MY MOM IS WATCHING
THIS!
>> Jesse: HI, MOM!
[LAUGHTER]
WE HAVE TO WATCH THE LEFT WING
GARBAGE ALL DAY, THAT'S WHY WE
DON'T TRUST IT.
THIS ANALOGY IS SO GOOD.
I HAD A FRIEND, WHENEVER HE MET
SOMEBODY, HE ASSUMED THAT PERSON
WAS A SEXUAL PREDATOR.
AND THEN HE WORKED BACK FROM
THAT ASSUMPTION.
RIGHT?
WHENEVER I SEE ANYTHING IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, I ASSUME IT'S
WRONG AND WORK BACK FROM THAT
ASSUMPTION.
EVERYBODY ELSE TO DO THAT.
AS YOU SAID, THIS HAS BEEN A
LONG TIME COMING TRADE WAS AT
THE WMDs IN IRAQ?
WAS IT THE DOSSIER?
WAS AT THE LAB LEAK CONNECT A
LAPTOP FROM HELL?
WAS IT BRETT KAVANAUGH, WAS IT
SMOLLETT?
WAS THAT CUOMO WAS A HERO AND
RON DeSANTIS WAS A ZERO?
>> Greg: A Q-TIP!
>> Jesse: ANYONE WITH ACCESS
TO THE Q-TIP, SEND IT OUR WAY.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
WHAT'S DIFFERENT NOW IN THE AGE
OF INFORMATION, JESSICA, IS THAT
WE HAVE ACCESS TO EVERYTHING
THAT THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA JUST
NEEDS TO HAVE ACCESS TO.
WE SEE THE NUMBERS, WE SEE THE
DEPOSITIONS.
WE ARE NOW SEEING FISA
APPLICATIONS, AND THE POLLING
INTERNALS FOR THE FIRST TIME.
IT'S EYE-OPENING HOW WE'VE BEEN
LIED TO, AND YET, EVEN THOUGH WE
HAVE ALL THIS INFORMATION, THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA CONTINUES TO
LIE TO US.
SO GREG IS RIGHT, YOU STEP ON
THE SCALE, YOU ARE 85, AND THEY
CONTINUE TO TELL YOU THAT YOU
ARE 105.
>> WHO IS 85 POUNDS?
>> Emily: FAKE NEWS!
[LAUGHTER]
>> Shannon: YOU GUYS MIGHT NOT
KNOW I LIKE TO LOOK ON THE BACK
SIDE OF THINGS.
I KEEP IT CLOSETED.
I LOVE THAT IT'S THE ONLY
INDUSTRY THAT GAIN FAVORABILITY,
POLICE.
THE ONLY ONE.
>> Jesse: WHAT DOES THAT TELL
YOU?
AFTER BEING DENIGRATED,